ladies and gentlemen welcome aboard my
name is russell and assisting me today
will be xanax and zoloft
i'm here for your safety and they're
here for my comfort
i'm doing the safety demo knowing full
well you're all ignoring me
i might as well be doing the macarena
there's absolutely no way that that's
gonna fit in the overhead compartment
but i'm gonna watch you try anyway i'm
not a bartender so i will not be
granting you a bloody mary with
worcestershire sauce oh
is this your newborn's first time flying
how could you do that to us
there's no turbulence i just turned on
the seatbelt sign because i want you to
stay the hell out of my way diet soda
takes forever to pour
here's a regular one you won't know the
difference pressing the call button
repeatedly isn't gonna make me tend to
you any faster
in fact it's going to make me go slower
when i said i would check your bag that
was a courtesy but you were rude so now
it's going to baltimore
you know the vodka we just ran out of we
used it to make crew juice in the galley
go ahead
tug my skirt one more time i dare you i
said pretzels
or peanuts this isn't an all-you-can-eat
buffet honey i have no idea we're flying
over right now
so i'll just say the bahamas since you
blatantly ignored the seatbelt sign
i hope the turbulence knocks you on your
ass oh you think i'm coming through the
cabin to pick up your trash
no i'm crop dusting enjoy smelling my
farts
you